Ringling Brothers Circus announced its  retiring all their elephants this year  that's good thing there's gonna be the  first time the circus has been without  elephants since they first introduced  them way back in 1882 I think this is  really good progress I do wait you think  it's good progress yes I happen to think  it's great progress I do not think  elephants should be forced into  captivity what does that mean you're  gonna force me to retire my elephant  marmalade please don't because that  elephant means everything to me  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  don't let you take in Snowden already  and subpoena okay Andy  you know marmalade isn't a real elephant  right it's just our stagehand big paw  wearing an elephant trunk puppet  of course I know that but he doesn't  come on Andy let's hit the shower all  right mom let's go  [Music]  incredibly stupid wasn't that a great  clip subscribe to my youtube channel for  an endless supply of me  [Laughter]